hello everyone and welcome to the final
day of the skilling open this is the
second match
uh between wesley so and magnus carlsen
now the first match ended in a draw for
those of you who maybe weren't uh
following the games ended by white
winning every single game
so magnus won two of his games with
white and wesley now also
and now we have the second day but it's
not like the game was uh
the games were one-sided the games were
completely crazy and anything could have
happened and now
uh we'll see what happens in day two
will they again uh
have a draw after four games and will we
see uh tie breaks or will
uh we have a a decision already in the
first four games
and also today's uh carlson's birthday
uh so he usually plays very well on his
birthday but we'll see what happens this
year so wesley has the white pieces and
he opens with
e4 and magnus already surprises him on
the first move by going c6 he chooses
the karo khan defense
and the wesley probably was not all that
prepared for that
as it took him some time to to decide on
a reply here
and after a few seconds uh sorry about
that uh he went
d4 so d4 by wesley we have d5
uh and e5 the advanced variation of the
karo khan now bishop to f5 and now
knight to d2 we have e6
closing this setup after the bishop has
been developed and now
shifting the knight over to b3 as uh
the d4 pawn will be nicely defended we
have knight to d7 by magnus
and knight to f3 with h6 and now bishop
to e2
so at this point both players were
playing relatively fast we have a5 and
a4 and here uh interestingly this
position has been reached in one game in
the database in 2011 milan bahar versus
uh marian cristovich in zagreb open
uh where uh uh c5 has been played and
black was able to win that game however
here
bishop to b for czech is played by
magnus and it is as
already as of move eight that we have a
completely new game and what happens now
is really really awesome because wesley
replies with c3 he creates this
wonderful setup attacks carlson's dark
square bishop
and magnus just retreats it all the way
back to f8 so
everyone was very much surprised to see
this because it's like
he gave wesley a free move uh but we'll
see what happens so here
at wesley castles and now knight the e7
so here
uh during the official broadcast they
thought that maybe carlson
was doing this funny maneuver just uh to
wait wesley to castle and then start
pushing on the king's side
but we'll see what happens here so h3 by
wesley
uh and now bishop back to h7 uh we have
bishop to d2 by wesley and now queen to
b6 developing the queen putting pressure
on the knight if the white queen moves
and now knight the e1 preparing this f4
uh f4 push uh and here knight to f5 by
magnus so this is an excellent outpost
for the knight if you want to kick it
away you either have to push it with the
g4
uh which means weakening your king or
maybe give up the the light square
bishop
uh which is not very likely so here
bishop to d3
putting the bishop on this diagonal but
not interested in the knight
so bishop to e7 and now queen to c2 here
sitting a little trapper for magnus
because if he decides to castle
kingside then g4 just wins the game on
the spot because you either lose the
knight or you move the knight and then
you lose the bishop with
check because there is now a double
attack here so of course
magnus did not castle he plays bishop to
g6
and now c4 by wesley and here we have
something very interesting
the captures on c4 we have queen
captures on c4 and now feel free to
pause the video and try to find
the absolute best move here while i give
you a couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding
a move that's not very easy to find uh
which magnus also uh
played and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's uh
knight captures on d4 and this is just a
really wild move because whatever
whatever white plays uh black will
always come out on top for example if
you go for the bishop on g6
then it's a really funky line knight
captures on b3
attacks the rook and the bishop here but
now queen
captures on e6 you cannot capture the
queen because the king would be in check
so here black would just castle queen
side now there's the threat of capturing
the queen
and after you capture on f7 let's say
now comes the knight capture sandy
you don't want to capture the rook
because the white queen will capture the
bishop so you're going to capture the
bishop
and only then capture the rook so queen
captures
knight captures and then after king
captures we would have this position
where black would have the upper hand
as he would have to uh well he would be
up the exchange a rook for a bishop
so that's what happens if you capture on
g6 another option instead of capturing
in g6 is to play knight captures on d4
but this is also
very tricky because here magnus would
have knight captures on e5 so attacking
both of these pieces
and the bishop would be attacked twice
and after the queen moves you just trade
captures captures and now bishop
captures or knight captures for that
matter of captures and captures
uh and now we get this position where
magnus is up two pawns and it would be
it would be very very difficult for
white to save this so
a lot was needed uh uh you know to be
calculated here
uh after magnus played knight characters
on d4 but uh wesley played the absolute
best move
queen captures on d4 so now he offers a
queen trade but also
leaves uh his knight undefended and
magnus just goes for it queen captures
on b3 uh
bishop captures on g6 at least uh he's
gonna double up black spawns because
he's now down upon
f captures and now queen e4 makes sense
as you go after the
uh g pawn and here uh probably bestest
uh guarded the pawn with the king with
king to f7 but magnus castled instead
and allowed wesley a very sneaky idea
bishop captures an h6 and this is just
crazy if magnus
accepts the bishop sacrifice then it's a
it's just a perpetual or
even more because after this check king
hit queen captures on h6
check king g8 white actually has rook to
c1 with the threat of rook c3 followed
by rook to g3
which would be deadly so uh very sneaky
idea by wesley but magnus finds the
absolute best defense uh
rook to f5 and now the queen no longer
has access to the g6 square
and now the bishop must retreat so
bishop back to e3
and now comes queen to d5 offering a
queen trade
uh or you move and then the the e5 pawn
falls so here uh wesley instead trades
we have
captures captures and now f4 saving the
pawn here
but only momentarily as magnus
immediately attacks it with the g5 he
wants the
mess up white spawn structure with e6
here
challenging the knight and not knight to
c5 so this pawn is now hanging and now
g4 now the rook has to move and here
wesley of course is hoping magnus will
move the rook and then
push the pawn all the way to f5 creating
this beautiful pawn chain
but magnus has something else in mind he
plays g captures on f4 and he sacrifices
the exchange
so here g captures an f5 f captures an
e3
creating this beautiful pass pawn but
the other uh the d-pawn is also a pass
pawn so
we will have two connected pass pawns in
the center and now
rook to f4 preventing this pawn from
being pushed but now bishop to f6
magnus now prepares to push it knights
to c2
going after the pawn here but now just
e2
we have rook to f2 going after the pawn
and now magnus plays d4 and now
not much to do here d3 is coming
followed by d2 so
what can you do here wesley uh decides
to give back some material he plays rook
captures on e2
just to get rid of those past pawns but
now d3
and okay rook d2 we have captures
captures and now
uh not even reacting to this knight
being under attack just playing rook
the d8 um as uh if the
if the knight is captured just bishop d4
check picks up that rook
uh so here after rook to d8 we have rook
to e1 and we have descend game
where wesley has two rooks but magnus
has a rook a knight in the bishop so two
pieces for the rook which is uh
which is of course much better however
wesley still has this past pawn so
magnus doesn't need to be a little bit
careful
so first knight captures on a4 and now
uh wesley switches the knight back to
the a file rook to a1
knight captures on b2 now and rook
captures on a5
so now magnus also with the two
connected pass pawns on the king's side
knight back to d3 and now king h2
we have knight the b4 charging the rook
here and
rook to c1 and here knight to d5 the
knight is nicely defended and on a nice
central square here
rook to a7 going after the pawn here but
now rook to b8 and now magnus is ready
to push those pawns we have king to g3
and now knight to e7 going after the f5
pawn
king g4 and now b5 now finally starts
pushing those pawns
rook to d1 and now b4 magnus says
there's uh there's no threat here we
have rook
a to d7 now uh hoping to trade off a
pair of rooks
but just b3 magnus says nothing is
really happening here we have rook d8 to
check
magnus trades once captures captures and
now
king to h7 uh and here rook to be it of
course you have to put the rook behind
the pass pawn
but uh b2 and this pawn is now nicely
protected by the bishop uh
wesley spawns can't really move so here
wesley played one more move king f4
and now after knight to d5 check uh it
was in this position that wesley so
resigned the game
as there is not much hope for this um
uh for his king because well everything
loses here
there's just nothing to do black will
just push this pawn and win the game
easily
or there are even tricks like king to e4
and then you can even bring the queen
into the game because after the rook
captures that knight c3
check and then you just win the rook and
now you're up two pieces
so whatever wesley place here is winning
for magnus so uh
resigning makes sense and like i said he
was in this position that wesley so
resigned the game
so an excellent victory for magnus on
his birthday
in the first game of their second match
we'll see what happens in the other
three
matches and will wesley be able to
bounce back and get back
so we can see some tie breaks or will
magnus just take it all the way in the
first four games
uh so that's uh the game i do hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
michael calbera uh paul mueller
uh steven salan brian mulstead and
joseph gilbert for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful tournament
the skilling open checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day